Cómo cree que debería conmemorarse este
día si cree que directamente debería
estar fijado como festivo en el
calendario
bueno como tal festivo significa que
habría una festividad Y en este caso no
sería una festividad porque
históricamente pues este día nació en
1913 cuando el exministro español
Faustino Rodríguez San Pedro decidió en
la como presidente en la unión
iberoamericana crear esta idea del día
de Colón para unir España y América cuál
es el problema al problema es que si tú
lo llamas como celebración entonces hay
que celebrar que Colón llegó a América
eso desencadenó una serie de matanzas de
enfermedades y de cuestiones que hoy en
día están revaluadas entonces
celebración como tal No pero sí es una
conmemoración de que ocurrió este hecho
de la colonización y que varios pueblos
indígenas también la esclavitud se
originó a raíz de esto y precisamente
las voces que van en la dirección que
usted comentaba en a recordar la
colonización pero no celebrarlo han
cogido fuerza en los últimos años o
simplemente se les ha prestado más Como
por ejemplo recordemos que en Estados
Unidos el presidente Joe biden el año
pasado decretó que ahí el 10 de octubre
cuando tiene lugar la celebración del
Día de Colón en Estados Unidos sería
también el día de los pueblos
originarios A qué se debe digamos Este
cambio en el discurso
bueno el cambio en el discurso se debe
básicamente a las actitudes de la
academia de escuchar otras diferentes
perspectivas no solamente de la historia
con mayúscula de pensarse como que
Colombia vino colonizó hizo todo acá lo
que ocurrió también en Estados Unidos
con la cuestión británica sino que
además Esto ocurrió de manera simultánea
o sea también las personas que eran
parte de estos territorios existían no
fueron descubiertas ellos ya vivían aquí
y es darle voz a estas personas darle su
participación en la historia y
precisamente no hablaba de esta
nomenclatura entre descubrimiento
llegada colonización Cómo se ahora los
estudiantes de América Latina sobre la
llegada de Colón ha cambiado en los
últimos años debería cambiar Claro que
sí pues se tienen dos partes la
contraposición que tenemos desde España
en donde se está hablando de el
Descubrimiento y todas estas miradas
reivindicativas que no solamente es el
descubrimiento sino que también es la
visión de los vencidos que diferentes
autores como gorman tratan y es decir no
solamente es que se descubrió sino que
aquí había personas que estaban viviendo
y que fueron interrumpidas en su vida
porque llegaron otras personas de otras
partes a decir que las descubrieron y se
impulsieron y terminaron trayendo
enfermedades muerte y pues diferentes
cuestiones sociales Pues que ya sabemos
que ocurrió